we go to breaking news now out of Sudan
where the country's transitional
government has agreed to hand over
former President Omar al-bashir to the
International Criminal Court he faces
charges of genocide war crimes and
crimes against humanity over the
conflict in Darfur Bashir was asked at
in April after months of nationwide
demonstrations this going out to Heber
morgan who joins us now live from
Khartoum Heba this is a major
development given he's been wanted by
the ICC for a long time now why is this
happening now well what's happening at
the moment is that the Sudanese
transitional government is in talks with
various armed groups in the South
Sudanese capital Juba some of those
groups are from Darfur where a war has
been raging since 2003 and one of the
main conditions of these armed groups is
transitional justice specifically having
former President Omar al-bashir hand it
over to the International Criminal Court
now what the Sudanese government
announced just under an hour ago is that
they have agreed with the Darfur armed
groups that they will hand over the
former president and others who also had
arrest warrants issued against them to
the International Criminal Court they
say this is part of achieving
transitional justice and they've also
said that there will be a hybrid Court
that will be established to make sure
that various other crimes that were
committed not just in Darfur but other
regions in Sudan are also tried for and
those criminals held to account they
also said that they will strengthen the
chief or rather traditional system in
the country to make sure that people who
have been affected by the war are gets
some kind of justice now let's go back
to the cost of the war over 300,000
people have been killed and Darfur alone
and more than 2 million people displaced
so the Darfur armed groups are saying
that this unless the Sudanese government
had agreed to handing over the former
president to the International Criminal
Court then the talks cannot go forward
and that is what the government has
agreed to now what comes next is for
them to settle security arrangements
before they sign a final peace deal and
then that becomes official what does
this tell us about the transitional
government Heba I mean they've been in
power for what a few months now what
does this tell us about how they want to
put Sudan back on the international
stage
well it seems that from what we heard
from the transitional government and
from the armed groups they say that they
were very keen to try to achieve peace
to make sure that there is some kind of
stability the conflicts in the various
parts of the countries the reason why
student economy has been deteriorating
and they say the core the core solution
to try to restore the country's economic
economy once again is to try to bring
stability so it looks like what they're
trying to do right now is more of an
internal issue to try to make sure that
they don't have any more interference
and that there is no instability
especially since as you say the
transitional government isn't that old
it was just formed in August last year
after months of political turmoil and
after months of talks between the
protest movement known as the forces of
freedom and change coalition and the
transitional military council that
Elstad former President Omar al-bashir
now they've previously also said that
this is not their case that handing over
the former president to the
International Criminal Court is not up
to them but up to an elected government
but it looks like that the talks between
the armed groups and the government has
reached a point where they had to offer
some concessions and it looks like
handing over the former president and
those who are also wanted alongside with
him is a concession they made to try to
get the talks moving so that they can
sign a deal before the deadline that
they agreed on which is the 14th of
February Thanks that that's Al Jazeera's
Heba morgen their live from Khartoum